and my biggest regrets in all of
investing
are actually the times that i sold
prematurely it's not having invested in
things
it is in
in other words it's not it's not having
missed opportunities to invest it's
having not
uh held the things i invested in for a
longer period of time
sorry shopify shopify was a huge one i
mean that was my biggest misfire of all
time was
but at the time that represented in
absolute dollars a really significant
win for me yeah to try to get to the
point where i didn't have to be
preoccupied
with money so it made sense right look
the logic of selling that actually made
sense
do i regret it yes
a better example would be in
2008
when i had
one
stock that i put a bunch of my like a
very double-digit percentage of my net
worth into can you guess what it was
and i put it in maybe in 2005.
uh wordpress
no
no although i am an advisor to wordpress
or rather to automatic and i'm a big fan
i think of what you would have bought
back then maybe amazon
yeah i bought amazon in like
2005 or something like that
uh maybe a little bit later
taking a look right now so wait you
regret that no you don't regret that
obviously that's something i regret
selling oh you sold it like three years
later i sold it when
the
subprime crisis landed and everything
was just going through the floor
and
boy oh boy that was a mistake should
have held on to it and i didn't have
clear rules for myself then right it was
i i had rules for buying but not rules
for holding or selling and i think
people at least i get my i've gotten
myself into a lot of trouble
by having rules for buying which i i
sort of intuitively have a pretty good
feeling for i think you have an even
better feeling for it honestly you're
just that's absolutely one of your
mutant powers
but then
how long to hold when to sell having
rules for that in advance
is something that i have historically
not been
as good at
and that has been a big problem uh
certainly with amazon as as sort of the
textbook example of that you know
selling 2008 on a panic and now it's
who knows five or 10x i have no idea
yeah oops and the other thing is that
when you think of yourself as an owner
of a business because that's the mindset
you have to be because the only way
you'll be able to keep
no one other than the walton family
has kept walmart stock from 1970 till
now
or even 1980 till now
or even 1990 till now
and why is that you know
is it not obvious it's a great business
is it not obvious that it has
you know
very strong
ethics and moat and all of that you know
there's a lot of things very obvious
about
about sam walton and walmart so just to
give you uh
and a little bit of example there
is
i made an i made an investment in uh
before my enlightenment of 2020. i made
an investment in 2019
in this company in turkey in istanbul
and
when i made the investment the
market cap of this company was 19
million dollars one nine
and uh the best that i could tell the
liquidation value of the business
because they they've got 12 million
square feet of warehouses
uh they have got the the largest freight
operations network
the largest truck fleet
in turkey and so on there were a bunch
of businesses liquidation value was
at least
around uh
500 million dollars or so
and
that wasn't even the best part
the people who ran the business were
exceptional capital allocators so i was
buying a business you know probably less
than five cents on the dollar
you know the kind of opposite of the
nifty 50 you can say
and
so i said okay this is great you know
we'll hold this for a while and and i
was lucky i think that because turkey
has got so much trading volume the
average holding period for most of the
retail investors is a few hours or a few
days they've got very high stock volumes
and buffer doesn't look another quote
that the stock market is a mechanism to
transfer wealth from the active to the
inactive and so
my funds own one third
of this company
now and we bought the one-third for
about seven million dollars
a little less than seven million
it's gone up about seven or eight times
in the last let's say 20 months or so
but
when i look forward maybe 10 or 20 years
and i say okay you know the intrinsic
value is 500 million
what do i think this father-son team
that runs it can do in terms of growing
intrinsic value so i'm thinking you know
probably on a bad day they probably
triple it in 10 years or something
or maybe
they might even do more than that so it
might it might be worth
maybe a billion and a half or something
in 20 30 maybe 10
you know 3x from where it is
so what do i need to do
i just need to
be really good at sitting on my ass
and nothing else the main challenge that
i have is to just spend all my time
talking to students at babson
for the next 10 or 15 years
and let the father to son team so they
they own like 40 odd percent of the
company i'm their you know idiot passive
minority investor and uh
happily cheering them on from the
sidelines
and their son is very young he's about
35 so i think this goes like a three
four decade runway so my first stop on
this business will be in 2030 to like
rip and rip van winkle wake up and say
oh where are we at oh we are a billion
and a half market cap okay that sounds
good and uh are they still kicking ass
yeah they're still kicking ass okay let
me go to sleep for another 10 years
and we'll wake up and see what's going
on after that so this company was
one and a half percent of our assets
when we invested right
and the other 90 and a half 98 and a
half percent is not exactly slouches
you know it wasn't invested in kodak at
100 times earnings i think those other
bets have some legs as well and so my
the number one skill you need to do well
as an investor
is extreme patience
so if you are the kind of person who
loves to watch
paint dry
this is the business for you
if you get really excited about watching
a white wall drying
this is just perfect for you
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you